can you say with a hundred percent
certainty that Tick Tock does not use
the phone's camera to determine whether
the content that elicits a pupil
dilation should be Amplified by the
algorithm can you tell me that we do not
collect body face or voice data to
identify our users the only face data
that you'll get that we collect is when
you use the filters to have sunglasses
on your face we need to know where your
eyes are data is stored here in American
soil your Tick Tock employees that live
in China they must cooperate with
Chinese intelligence whenever they are
called upon and if they are called upon
they're bound to secrecy that would
include you so Mr Chu if the CCP tells
bite dance to turn over all data that
Tick Tock has collected inside the US
even within project Texas do they have
to do so we hear these concerns we
didn't try to avoid them or you know
trivialize them we built something where
we take that data and put it Out Of
Reach
foreign